um it is a brutal world that you've
created
people die um families are ruined it's
war i mean we we
are in war when we're reading a song of
ice and fire
um that is different than a lot of
fantasy fiction
yes what difference is that to you and
and
you know you embrace the fantasy genre
but those qualities are different than
many fantasy books
you know i i will say that uh fantasy is
changing
and maybe i had some some small part in
in it changing
if you read some of the younger fantasy
writers who have come along
in the last five years or so
um i think their work reflects more
realism but you know the modern fantasy
largely grew out of the work of j.r
tolkien and his great landmark lord of
the rings which looms over
all fantasy like a like a mountain and
everybody else is operating in the
shadow of tolkien what he did
uh and my admiration for tolkien and his
work is second to none
i think lord of the rings is one of the
great novels of the 20th century perhaps
the greatest novel the 20th century as
it was voted recently by the
the readers of the uh the guardian i
think in england
um to the fury of uh some of the people
in the literary establishment
who wanted it to go to like james joyce
or nabakov or somebody and instead it
went to uh
to tolkien uh but that being said
following lord of the rings
fantasy was largely taken over by
tolkien imitators
who were delivering tolkien like books
but uh who didn't seem to capture any of
the power of tolkien
and just were borrowing some of his
tropes and some of the things that
tolkien did which i think worked for him
in the hands of these lesser writers
developed into
pretty bad cliches and you know the
whole thing of the dark lord
is is stirring and his ugly minions are
coming out and you know they're
they're horrible minions because they're
ugly and they're
and they wear black and bad they have a
lot of
spikes and stuff on their armor and um
you know and the good guys go forth and
they're all like elves and stuff like
that and they're really
pretty and they they were white and
you know the world is not that simple uh
good guys and bad guys is is fun when
you're seven but
uh you know you should you should look
around and see what the world is like
and grow more than that
and i wanted to kind of reflect to weld
fantasy with the
historical fiction and uh which is more
gritty and realistic and to to capture
some of what i see is the
real moral ambiguity of these these
issues because real human beings are not
you can't tell the bad people because
they're ugly or they're good people
because they're pretty
and uh you know i deliberately turn some
of these conventions on their head i
mean the night's watch
yeah they're a bunch of scum but they're
heroic scum
and they're protecting and yet they were
black you know so
uh i was doing that i took ravens which
of course in
in tolkien and the imitators of these
birds of ill
omen and horrible things and i made them
uh
basically a good thing a means of of uh
flying from castle to castle and
delivering uh messages and so forth so
often i was i was deliberately playing
with and and you know the guys in white
the night's watch or nothing the uh the
kingsguard
or white but it's an institution that
was once heroic but is now hopelessly
corrupt
full of political appointees and uh
you know people who are venal or brutal
or greedy and
appointed for anything with the original
reasons so i was playing with all of the
all of the tropes and turning a few
things on their head